in short when we render images to the
screen a pixel and layout dimensions may
well not equal a pixel in real device
terms and that relationship isn't a
fixed one either here we have the same
page on two different devices but even
though the image is approximately the
same size on both devices this image
only needs less than half the pixels of
this image to be rendered at 121
rendering an image at 121 gives the best
quality but even more important you
don't want to be pushing a lot more bits
down the network then the device can use
and you don't want to have poor image
quality because you're not pushing
anywhere near enough high resolution
imagery either the best way to think
about this is that it's much like the
difference between standard definition
TV and high-definition TV for most of my
life I watch standard definition TV but
now that i watch most shows in HD when a
show is broadcast in standard def I
definitely feel like I'm living like an
animal you need to deliver an HD
experience when the user's device
supports it